one in three women in the EU has
suffered sexual or physical violence
sometime in their life since they were
15 years old that is more than 62
million women 5% have been raped which
corresponds to 9 million women that is
equivalent even more than the entire
population of Austria fifty-five percent
have been sexually harassed since the
age of 15 wyd thirty-two percent of
these victims said that the perpetrator
was their boss their cru leak or a
customer eighteen percent have
experienced stalking eleven percent have
been confronted with cyber harassment so
all added up this is no minor issue we
are talking about mothers sisters
daughters across the EU who have been
abused physically sexually and
psychologically this is important that
the European Commission's next strategy
for equality between women and men makes
the impact of violence against women on
all women a priority I'm convinced that
the Istanbul Convention can help to
ensure that women throughout the EU are
finally treated not as objects to be
dealt with but as subjects with rights
now we need change change to ensure
existing legislation is implemented that
they especially support available for
victims and that we tackle violence
against women before it happens and for
this we need political leadership
resources and a concerted effort from us
all so as you heard its 28 European
Union member states about 1,500
interviews per member state and in total
interviews with 42,000 women
so it's the largest multi-country study
on violence against women that has been
conducted to date in the world most
women are not contacting anybody even
after what they consider to be the most
serious incident of sexual violence so
if they've been a victim of sexual
violence by any partner only thirty-nine
percent of women aren't going anywhere
and if they've been a victim of sexual
violence by someone else only thirty
percent of women are going anywhere so
that tells you the other seventy percent
etc are not going anywhere fifty-five
percent have been sexually harassed even
when we took out some of the categories
of sexual harassment to say let's look
at the mall so-called serious aspects it
was still forty-five percent there is a
need for policy responses from different
fields working together because we
looked at violence against women in
different settings we looked at domestic
violence we looked at stalking sexual
harassment we need responses from
employment health the education sector
that's just three examples working
together we need to look critically as
societal and state responses we need to
look at the scope and implementation of
existing law and policies once people
ratify the Istanbul convection
convention once the EU victims directive
is up and running in all Member States
we have to say what's the reality on the
ground the victims directive refers to
gender-based violence but we have to see
what is the reality on the ground are
more women going to report violence all
the service is going to be there for
them we need to target men and women
because to take this issue forward if
you see it as a women's issue it's
obviously not it's about gender equality
it's a men and women's issue we also
collected the support of 110 NGOs
worldwide for the support of the
Istanbul and ratification of the
Istanbul Convention calling again and
again and again on all 28 member states
and the Commission to ratify the
convention now we hope that with the
procedure with the treaty we will be
able
encourage and not just encourage we will
be able to push the European Commission
to commit towards this issue but also
the council the Member States all of us
each of us we have to work in our member
states with our governments and with our
Parliament's because it will take us a
long long long time to find a common
solution a fair solution it's not enough
to say we have a law on violence or
against women or a law on domestic
violence something which every country I
think should tackle also is the
perpetrators they are an important
factor in the equation because unless
perpetrators are treated they are
removed from one relationship but then
they go on to another relationship and
they commit violence there as well but
these are I mean are the two main things
that you should approach first every
members they should ratify the Istanbul
Convention and then the Commission
should put forward a comprehensive
legislated that cover all kind of
violence against women there's a very
strong commitment of course more needs
to be done and more will be done I think
the ratification of the Istanbul
convention is a very very important
point and ratification should progress
by by member states it would be a pity
if we stop with the survey here I think
we should have the possibility to see
the evolution of violence against women
in Europe over time the prevalence of
violence against women is a you means
one thing we all have an obligation to
act because not enough is being done
despite efforts undertaken in recent
years too many women are still affected
by violence were there is violence there
can be no equality and the quality
between win men and women
lays at the heart of the European values
today Europe takes another step forward
in the struggle to eradicate real
violence against women for too long it
has been a hidden scandal we need to
know the problem in order to fix it the
landmass survey that the fundamental
rights agency has presented today
represents a real breakthrough its scale
and we got our unique and it has given a
voice to the victims of violence at
least